I would say many individuals like they
are one way or the other familiar with
cancer and
actually my mother died of
breast cancer and my goal is basically
to try to endow T cells with better
anti-cancer properties
T cells are a subset of white blood
cells that are able to contribute to
fighting off infections
linoapato is an immunologist that has
been studying T cells for more than 15
years
I got interested in T cells like because
during my PhD we were wondering to find
how chemotherapies could somehow in
precise situation harness the immune
system and I remember that was one of
the
experiments I did at the time was to
compare how
wild type mice with a full immune system
and immune diffusion mice like in T
cells respond to local radiotherapy
and actually we found that T cells were
essential for the efficiency of
chemotherapy if mice were devoid of
those T cells they were not responding
as well as control mice to the treatment
tiso seemed to be playing a critical
role in fighting off cancer
and liner was interested in boosting
those abilities that led him to
cytokines signaling proteins that help
control the immune system including
binding to T cells and making them more
aggressive
far that there are there
of T cells that secrete a chemical
mediator like called interleukin9 and
those T cells are particularly potent in
eliminating cancer cells these cells
known as th9 cells deal with cancer by
rallying over immune cells to their
cause
they secrete the cytokine interleukin9
which activates other immune cells to
bind to and Destroy cancerous tumors
th9 cells appear to be particularly
effective at dealing with some tumors in
part because they keep their anti-cancer
properties longer than other kinds of
cells
so Lionel has been trying to further
improve their abilities so we are trying
to understand how these cells develop
how we can further enhance their
anti-cancer properties so that then they
are really
um potent in eliminating cancer cells
Lino and his team have found that
cytokines are not only produced by the
th9 cells but the cells are also
affected by different kinds of cytokines
in fact specific mixtures of cytokines
seem to improve the anti-cancer ability
Lionel hopes to take samples of th9
cells from a person with cancer and
convert them into better longer lasting
cancer Fighters using cytokine cocktails
and then transfer them back into the
body to fight the tumor
but at the same time it's a balance they
can't be too aggressive and uh clearly
that's a challenge because those cells
might be somehow triggering like
unwanted effects or they might become
harmful
after transfer to individuals so that's
where it's kind of a balance between
like also
aggressiveness against cancer cells not
being harmful to the cells of our own
body but it isn't just aggressiveness
that Lionel needs to manage
afterwards after transfer to the
patients like what is important those T
cells should be able to keep those
properties to mediate their anti-cancer
effect in the long run they should be
able to persist
I would be really happy to see like in
terms of Hope like if we could transfer
this uh
in the the clinical setting our goal
would be to bring that to a phase one
first thing called trial and then
ideally
test if those th9 cells can be
successful in trading
patients liking possibly face to
clinical trials
I know the stakes and it's hard but
sometimes
the hardest part was really like when I
when I meet with patients
because then of course
um
in a way she is rewarding because like
we are trying really to help them but
it's also very like on the emotional
point of view that's also very that's
also a major challenge
because
also that we need to we need to pursue
we need to do uh we need to do better
and
um so it's mixed feelings basically and
if like we would be able like to again
come up with solutions for even like a
small portion of patients like I would
really regard this like personally has
uh as a major achievement
oh